welcome to this video blitz game against
Jimmy jaja from the UK and playing a
comic con I have the fantasy variation
yeah I have no idea again this against
this line yeah its success sort of the
main move oil there's also a 5 and stuff
like that I apply six sets am at least
something I know hmm yeah this is very
similar to to to the French now and now
we actually transpose until the French
see 5 or c-51 move later the French
defence a classical French an opening
that very much is out of fashion I go in
the classical with Bishop g5 Bishop e7
this is out of fashion some has a
slightly passive reputation okay but now
I'm not playing passively i'm playing c4
I'd be five yeah this is White's counter
play but this is a actually very
dangerous for for white when I was some
silly junior player I remember that I
got into this is white and I lost
terribly I mean like very quickly with
it because black simply pushes pawns
here before c3 and um you don't really
have so much on the other side you have
to say I actually just thought about
them maybe white should should go for
this kind of radical solution getting
getting the Queen self maybe I should
have prevented this somehow
and I'm not sure I want to play
something like a curry to tween to f7 or
something this looks like it's treatable
but maybe quidsi sam neill why not Queen
c7 it cannot be attacked there that
still have before C 3 and so on ok so is
there some threat Queen h5m probably
queen edge 500 is a thread well not a
super dangerous threat but term it is it
is on what if I place III or Castle
castle see we play ma'am we cannot blow
Bishop d3 with this is very very
important so we cannot improve the
position with this but let's just castle
here night h5 threatening Knight to f6 I
am maybe just plugging a jade he lacks
his special p.m. in the attack and I'm
very quick actually I mean I'm playing
defense moves with Queen c7 and castles
but I'm very quick with c3 if I go 33 at
some point that immediately I will get
dangerous alright so how to proceed here
in the attack this move is not really
doing much yeah let's um let's get this
night into some attacking position can
also play Queen a 52 before and an
attack on the pawn b2 is not so easy to
to parry um I could also have a curved
plate ac3 but the problem with this move
is that he can ignore it so look f1 hmm
what happens if i'm just-just advanced
here with my pieces it looks some
dangerous go into h5 threatens 93 93
isn't this okay I may be no he doesn't
have firm so no no he doesn't have King
see one I Kevin yeah this is just made
oh I'm I completely blind here Quincy to
made yeah i'm not completely blind for
once yeah i think in this position he
probably must play a three but is also
good night c 3 a 3 then then this is oh
no so a 3 here the sacker confused yeah
here I actually thought that I could
maybe just retreat but at the computer
pretty much tells me that this is not
possible so maybe I was lucky here nie
Dage 5 I thought online age 5 I could go
rook a seven but maybe this is Sir
this assumption is completely wrong
night h4 is good and white is winning
hmm your that's quite some pieces I
don't really see it yet but what exactly
is threat and maybe it takes and rook
everyone something like this but the
computer gives it this is plus 8 so it
must be completely winning Knight f6 so
maybe I return here what is what is he
doing I sky druga everyone also on Queen
takes of course iam yeah then this is
this is quite much and I don't really
have an attack yet I see that so um this
means the Queen takes a five was was bad
but I have a winning move yet the
computer just wants to take and says I'm
winning wow how is this working out King
takes and now Queen a 50 K and hear what
Queen before yeah me too pink elephant
cannot protect me to sampling and this
is this is over yeah okay we have played
maybe Queen a five or ten too quickly I
thought it just looks good yeah but then
this is this as possible and however it
now gives night h4s being only slightly
better for black 0.71 yeah an
interesting game important though is
that here castles due to c4 is really
not good and I probably need to play
something else and some point here
castles there's also the move see 3 yeah
I didn't I didn't want to go
go there because I thought maybe I'm not
threatening so much I thought just drew
cook everyone or something but there's
the night before amongst others or take
and then this move they had in this of
course yeah i forgot about about this
this issue the night can come to see
three this is probably just winning for
black yeah alright thanks for watching
this